in this video we'll look back at how
valve built the foundations of the
metaverse daos and even nfts a decade
ago all while creating some of the most
fascinating economic research ever when
he was at microsoft in the early 90s
gabe newell commissioned a survey of
what programs people had on their home
computers the second most widely
installed software was windows number
one doom gabe became transfixed by the
idea that a small company that shipped
games via shareware could get its
software onto more computers than the
thousand pound gorilla that was windows
after he and his colleague mike
harrington left microsoft gabe knew that
he wanted to build a new kind of gaming
company valve was founded in 1996. the
company formation papers were signed on
the same day as gabe's wedding the
studio's first three games quickly
became the stuff of legend first
half-life released in november of 1998
then team fortress in 1999 which began
its life as a mod for quake before valve
acquired the team behind it finally
counter-strike released the following
year quickly became the world's most
popular online shooter following a wild
couple of years including mike's
amicable departure and the theft of
half-life 2 source code valve released
steam in 2003 but the revolution really
began in 2005 when the first third-party
games were released on the platform this
is when people realized that steam was
more than just a storefront for valve's
games it gave developers an alternative
to conventional retail for shipping
their products although digital
distribution didn't match retail volume
the lack of physical products enabled
valve and developers to achieve greater
profit margins by 2007 big publishers
like id software who created the
massively popular doom had started
distributing via steam by then steam had
15 million active users who could choose
from more than 200 games many of these
games had already developed vibrant
communities remember that by 2007 the
first generation of mmos had really
arrived around 10 million gamers were
actively playing world of warcraft so
this idea of playing with other people
and interacting via in-game chat was
already well established but players
weren't just planning raids and hanging
out in-game chat also enabled the
exchange of items if player a had a cool
item which player b wanted and vice
versa the two could coordinate to
exchange them in effect they began
bartering then when the demand for an
item say a hat and team fortress 2 which
were very popular rose sufficiently the
players would step out of the game meet
up on ebay trade the item for real
dollars and then come back to the game
where the seller would give it to the
buyer valve noticed this and decided
that they wanted to facilitate these
transactions while also taking some of
the revenues so in 2007 valve launched
the steam community market the community
market didn't invent the concept of
spending real money on virtual items but
it solved an important economic problem
barter markets need to overcome what's
called the double coincidence of wants
this means that it wasn't enough for
people to want to just buy and sell they
had to agree to exchange exactly what
one of them was offering for exactly
what the other person had by introducing
real world money to serve as a medium of
exchange valve made it much easier to
trade digital assets around this time
steam was basically a monopoly it didn't
have any meaningful challengers in
digital pc game distribution until 2007
when microsoft released games for
windows so it did more than any single
platform to popularize the idea of
exchanging virtual items for real money
over the years this has led to some
pretty wild stories you can still find
old youtube videos and questions on
sites like quora asking if it's possible
to make a living trading on the steam
community market in one answer someone
named kevin frye said that a buddy of
his made enough money from the community
market to buy a ford f-350 truck a beach
house in north carolina and even pay for
college steam users in places as far
away as kazakhstan were earning a living
by providing services and creating items
it's no coincidence that kazakhstan is
now one of the world's leading bitcoin
mining locations it also blurred the
once solid boundaries between producers
and consumers according to gabe there
were employees of other companies who
were actively working at independent
game studios that made more money
producing steam assets than the salaries
they made doing their day jobs suddenly
anyone could be a creator counter-strike
global offensive even birthed an entire
skin gambling industry where people
would bet skins which had real world
value on third party websites a couple
of years ago valve investigated and
halted trading of some in-game items
after discovering that nearly all of the
trading was linked to money laundering
networks it didn't end there though in
may 2013 valve launched steam trading
cards digital collectibles which could
be crafted into game badges and
subsequently exchanged for items such as
profile backgrounds and coupons for game
discounts or dlc after the project left
beta players needed to purchase the few
final cards to complete their set for a
supported game by buying them on the
steam community market demand for
trading cards initially rose to the
point where according to valve it became
significant enough that there was an
economic opportunity worth taking
advantage of and that was when the fake
developers arrived according to a valve
blog post these scammy developers would
upload fake games to steam and generate
steam keys the keys were then
distributed to bots running steam
accounts which passively accumulated
trading cards the problem became bad
enough that steam created a confidence
metric to test if games were actually
being played by genuine users cards
would only be allocated to players of
that game if it reached the required
confidence metric today most of the
steam trading cards sell for a dollar or
two there are more valuable ones though
which usually require a significant
achievement within a game trading and
speculating on digital items didn't
start with nfts it didn't even
technically begin with steam but steam
did way more than any other platform to
popularize the concept of creating and
exchanging digital items for real cash
don't be surprised if many of the people
boosting nfts today were buying trading
cards or selling hats and skins on the
steam community market in the early
2010s by late 2011 steam had more than
40 million active users which they had
attracted through a growing library of
games and a unique experience that no
other company could match steam was an
immersive virtual community actually it
was a community of communities gamers
were initially drawn in purely by the
prospect of playing the games they
bought but they hung around to trade
items and share mods they'd made for
those games before long they began
creating meaningful experiences with
each other they made friends met
partners watched movies together talked
about the news the place on steam where
you hung out became like the bar where
everyone knows your name you go there
because that's where your friends are
and because you know you'll have a good
time add this all together and it's
clear that whether valve knew it or not
they had succeeded in creating an
ecosystem which closely resembled what
people today call the metaverse with its
own economies cultures and norms of
conduct gaming was the ideal first use
case for the proto-metaverse because
gamers were already spending hours of
their lives online in reality adding
immersive social and economic elements
was only one step further down a road
they were already traveling on gabe
newell understood that the communal
experience on steam was a vital part of
valve's brand as well as an important
part of why their user retention was so
strong but he also understood that he
had his own version of a very common
problem faced by leaders of successful
tech companies how to smoothly scale up
and meet the challenges created by
growth the most popular games on steam
quickly created economies that were so
large they simultaneously excited and
spooked valve items that had originally
been distributed for free were sometimes
trading for thousands of dollars on ebay
what kept gabe up at night was how to
ensure that the prices of these suddenly
lucrative items wouldn't just crash it
was a tricky problem but he realized it
wasn't a novel one because he knew that
when he turned on the tv he saw a
similar problem unfolding in europe the
european debt crisis is really
complicated the ultra short explanation
is that some countries with big economic
problems massive recessions high
unemployment slumping investment were
prevented from devaluing their currency
because they were locked in a monetary
union with the other countries on the
euro this meant they couldn't realign
their economic fundamentals with the
value of their currency which in turn
massively increased their cost of
borrowing and the chance that they would
default on their debt gabe was afraid
that something like the eurozone crisis
could emerge on steam as certain games
and in-game items became more popular
and valuable than others he needed the
advice of an expert he found one in the
form of giannis varufakas giannis would
go on to become greece's finance
minister and remains in the country's
parliament to this day but at the time
giannis was an associate professor of
economic theory at the university of
athens he was also one of the most
sought after expert voices on the debt
crisis and in frequent media appearances
strongly criticized the role played by
the european union and the european
central bank gabe thought giannis could
bring a unique perspective to the
problems valve was facing so with all
the optimism of someone who had built an
industry-leading tech company from
nothing he sent him an email at first
giannis thought the message in his inbox
was from yet another crackpot with a
secret plan to solve the crisis but he
was intrigued enough to read on the
email continued i have been following
your blog for a while here at my company
we were discussing an issue of linking
economies in two virtual environments
creating a shared currency and wrestling
with some of the thornier problems of
balance of payments when it occurred to
me this is germany and greece a thought
that wouldn't have occurred to me
without having followed your blog rather
than continue to run an emulator of you
in my head i thought i'd check to see if
we couldn't get the real you interested
in what we are doing giannis was no
gamer he was a professor who had
published books on game theory and
political economy he often referred to
himself as an errant marxist but he was
open-minded and interested in gabe's
offer and given that he was about to
travel to the states to promote his
latest book he decided to make an extra
stop and visit the valve headquarters in
seattle giannis met gabe and some of the
team he didn't really know what to
expect but he was definitely impressed
he immediately understood that he was
talking to smart people who cared about
what he had to say the more giannis
learned about valve the more excited he
became because in addition to helping
them solve their growth problem he
realized he had stumbled onto a hidden
paradise it's often said that the thing
preventing economics from being a real
science is that we don't have a second
earth that economists can use as a
control in experiments and the economy
we do have is just too messy to measure
relationships with complete certainty
giannis understood that within steam he
could perform the kind of experiments he
had always dreamed of but could never
actually execute every action left a
digital trail every item could be
accounted for and every exchange was
instantly and reliably recorded he could
dial up or down different settings and
observe changes in prices and behaviors
he was hired as valve's first ever
economist in residence and got right to
work it's amazing to go back and read
the blog posts he published about his
work he built an index to see if players
could make profits buying and selling
items in team fortress 2 without any
risks turns out that you could
especially when sales brought an influx
of new players he ran randomized control
trials on different pricing strategies
he studied in-game behaviors to see if
an item emerged as a reserve currency
that the value of other items were
measured against kind of like a virtual
us dollar yes was the answer to that
hypothesis it was hats and team fortress
it was an amazing story some of the most
exciting economic research of the decade
was being conducted at a gaming company
giannis and the rest of the team at
valve were learning tons about the steam
community but giannis was also learning
about what a remarkable company gabe had
built right at the top of this video i
mentioned that while he was still at
microsoft gabe commissioned a survey to
learn what programs were installed most
often on people's pcs those findings
really stuck with him gabe came to
believe that the true lesson of doom's
incredible success was that a startup
can create much more value by focusing
everything on creating innovative and
diverse new products instead of
delivering the same product with
incremental improvements so he resolved
to build a company that optimized for
the talent and creativity of its
engineers while getting rid of all the
unnecessary bureaucracy and bottlenecks
the valve handbook for new employees is
not your average onboarding guide how
can you not love something that calls
itself a fearless adventure in knowing
what to do when no one's there telling
you what to do that wasn't just a sound
bite it was the truth what was the point
valve asked of recruiting the most
intelligent innovative talented people
on earth only to obliterate 99 of their
value by chaining them to a desk and
telling them what to do that's a good
way to drain innovation out of people
and replace it with frustration so valve
was flat truly flat no one reported to
anyone else gabe was the founder and
president but even he wasn't anyone's
manager projects were greenlit by an
employee proposing them and persuading
colleagues of their value if your
colleagues liked your project they
joined it leads emerged informally and
once a project was done you could just
ship it without seeking permission the
handbook even made a big point of
explaining that the reason all the desks
had wheels was so that they could be
moved around to create new
configurations of workers and new
opportunities for collaboration just as
it had blurred the boundaries between
consumers and producers valve was
blurring the boundaries that had
traditionally separated workers from
managers this was all pretty crazy and
there were several reasons why it could
only really work in a company like valve
first and most obvious was elite talent
valve employees were trusted to ask the
right questions and apply the right
solutions another reason was valve's
reasonably small size today valve is
thought to have around a thousand
employees but a decade ago it was much
smaller just over 300 that kept quality
high and confusion low valve was also
entirely self-funded without outside
investors occupying board seats and
influencing business strategy valve
could become the kind of company its
workers wanted giannis saw that valve
wasn't just internally democratic it
worked like a free market he had long
been curious about the fact that the
vast majority of companies which are
these huge engines of capitalism
actually behaved much more like planned
economies thanks to the insights of
ronald coase we know why this is the
case traditional firms emerged as a way
of reducing transaction costs which
would grow too high if people had to
continually bargain and contract with
each other but valve was different
decisions weren't made from on high
people weren't listened to because they
had a more impressive title they were
listened to because others could see
that their ideas were going to generate
value for the company the only boss who
really mattered was the customer this
was audacious and because valve was so
committed to its principles it was
successful so to recap valve was
radically decentralized it was highly
autonomous and by adhering to a totally
flat organizational structure and
encouraging steam users to create and
share in-game assets it almost totally
erased traditional hierarchies you see
where i'm going with this don't you it
may have existed half in the real world
and half in the virtual world but when
you put valve and steam together you get
a three letter word dao it's incredible
to look back and realize how many of the
foundations of web 3 were actually built
by valve a decade ago the main concept
underpinning the metaverse people
creating meaningful experiences in
virtual communities was established in
large part by steam virtual items and
trading cards helped establish norms of
digital ownership and user-generated
revenue that echo nfts valve and steam
together function like the first dow
where workers could spontaneously come
together to do a sprint for an
individual project and then part ways
beyond these individual elements the
spirit of web 3 immersive decentralized
virtual environments that allow
horizontal collaboration and value
creation owes so much to valve the
products they built and the communities
they nurtured neither valve nor steam
were doing anything as advanced from an
engineering perspective as the people
making top-notch d5 protocols today but
valve its workers and its users built a
new type of internet together they built
the foundations for web3 even though
valve familiarized millions of people
with the core concepts that underpin
web3 there are still tons of skeptics
out there the biggest web 3 skeptic of
all is none other than elon musk so to
find out why elon hates web3 so much you
have to watch this video next thanks a
lot